I gotta say something's been freaking me
out for the past like hour and if you've
seen this what's behind you I thought
that was a human being I thought that
was a person I didn't know that was a
fictitious character and not regular
sighs yeah looks just like my home yeah
this is in our kitchen seen the footage
of this rooftop well I mean I did this
movie 13 hours where I did my first
physical transformation in my career and
that really started it all for me
because I think when I got in that good
of shape I thought I'd be pretty stupid
to lose it at this point so I stayed in
shape and then when I got this role I
was already in shape a little bit but as
far as the stunt training and everything
it's really about focus and its really a
dance it really comes down to
choreography so it's more about
preparation and being with our amazing
stunt team and getting to talk it over
every step of the way and make sure we
all feel safe and test it out rehearse
rehearse and so it's really it's just
one of those things where by the time
you actually do it you just hope there's
nothing that can go wrong and I say that
now the next times I do I'll just fall
right it oh well yeah
so Kendall loves the show I know you
shop but I see someone in Montreal but
it's not part of it I mean it was a
large majority was shot in Montreal we
had the best time
yes season two I know the tone is very
different so what would you change for
fans well I think season two my favorite
part about season two is the moral
ambiguity of Jack I think the season one
he's sort of briefly so called the Boy
Scout by everybody he's a really clean
cut guy who thinks the world's black and
white he very quickly realizes the
world's not black and white that it's
gray and that part decisions have to be
made in order to make change so I think
coming into season two he's willing to
make those hard decisions a lot more
readily and I think that leads him to be
a grittier character it leads a sort of
the storylines to be a little more
dangerous and certainly in the action to
be bigger right now I know I don't if
you get sick of hearing I'm a massive
office fan if they need to show like
four times ever I think you saw the poll
that went viral for Chrissy Teigen
a few weeks ago where she first talked
about it's the reverse of Jim Pam yeah
70% of people thought they're still
together the second place was open
marriage they think
Genesis together what do you think ten
years later what's going on with your
pants okay we have to so be together we
have to still be together
although maybe in a reunion show we're
not you heard it here for no you didn't
hear anything
I was just ever talk about like working
together again like maybe then something
completely differently Jack Ryan or
something does that mean I would love to
work on anything with Jenna she is the
absolute greatest actress but also the
more more than that the most amazing
person so I would love to spend all my
time with her like thank you very much
thank you